>>Presenter: Good afternoon, everyone.
My name's Dave Sparks.
I'm a software engineer on Google Project
Glass.
I'm here to introduce Marty Brounstein, who
I've known for about 12 years now.
I first met Marty when I was managing an RND
center that had some organizational issues.
Marty is the founder of the company called
Practical Solutions Group.
He has written a number of books on, basically,
organizational effectiveness, and runs a practice
in training people.
So Marty came in and helped me reorganize
the unit, and basically help our productivity,
things like that.
I was very surprised when Marty approached
me, I guess it was about a year ago, and said
he'd been working on a new project.
It wasn't another management book.
By the way, he's written, I think, four or
five--
>>Marty Brounstein: Seven.
>>Presenter: --seven management books.
Communicating for Dummies and Managing Teams
for Dummies--
>>Brounstein: Coaching.
Mentoring--
>>Presenter: Yeah, Coaching and Mentoring
for Dummies.
So he's quite an accomplished author already.
But I was rather surprised by the book that
he decided he was going to write.
It's basically a story of a Dutch couple during
World War II in occupied Netherlands who put
their lives at risk for other people.
So take it away, Marty.
>>Brounstein: Okay.
Thank you, Dave.
Yeah, applause, I definitely would appreciate.
[light applause and laughter] Thank you, thank
you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
[audience mumbles]
>>Brounstein: Let me try that again.
Good afternoon, everyone.
>>audience: Good afternoon.
>>Brounstein: Get ready to get involved in
an amazing story that I'm going to take you
through.
To start this journey into this remarkable
story about two heroes, I want you to be thinking
about these three questions.
Question number 1: would you be willing to
help others whose lives are in great danger?
Think about that.
Question 2: would you be willing to help others
whose lives are in great danger, knowing that
if you get involved to help, you'd probably
put your life in great danger?
Would you still help?
And question 3: would you be willing to help
others whose lives are in great danger, knowing
that if you get involved, you'd probably put
your life in great danger, when these people
who most need that help, most everybody else
wants to either hate them or be indifferent
to their plight?
Would you still get involved and help?
[pause]
'Two Among the Righteous Few: A Story of Courage
in the Holocaust' is a true story about a
Christian couple who answered a definite "Yes"
to all three of those questions in a time
period when most everybody else said, "No."
And to give this book its just due, I should
say its title is this: [speaks Dutch] That's
the title of this book translated into Dutch.
As you heard Dave mention, this story takes
place in the Netherlands, commonly referred
to as Holland, during World War II and the
Holocaust.
This couple I'm referring to are a husband
and wife named Frans and Mien Wijnakker.
They are true heroes of this story.
Doing something in a climate of hate and indifference
when most people wouldn't get involved, these
ordinary folks will end up doing extraordinary
things.
I'm going to take you into this story in just
a moment.
I'm going to be starting with you, and we'll
see what you know about the greater context
of the history going on at this time period.
Because when you understand that, it's going
to make what they did even look more remarkable,
because it was.
I'll also take you into life in Holland during
the war.
Very difficult time period there.
And then I'll be talking to you about who
Frans and Mien Wijnakker are, --who they were,
they're not alive today-- and what they end
up doing that is so heroic.
The last piece I'm going to talk to you about
is I have a personal connection to this story.
You see, as I pause for a moment here, this
is a story that I stumbled into by accident
a little over three years ago.
As Dave was telling you, he knows me from
very different things.
This is not part of my normal work.
It wasn't.
It's become, now, a big part of my life.
This story I stumbled into by accident, not
by design.
It's developed over time.
We can talk about it when I open up the floor
afterwards for your questions about the journey
of this.
I'm very, very much appreciative when I get
a chance to share this with an audience.
Let's first give a hand.
I want to thank Dave for helping make this
happen, for me today to come here.
[applause]
>>Brounstein: Since the book came out, which
is just last fall, today marks my 65th event
in sharing this story with an audience, of
all sizes, all places.
We've often had, I hope, afterwards, you come
up and talk to us.
Books, Inc. is here to help you if you want
to buy a book, as well.
We've had people come up and be supporters
for us.
They've gotten this into their workplace,
or their church, synagogue.
My kids' school, they said.
I've had some people came up and said, "I'll
host one in my home for you."
So we've had a variety of that kind of support.
Others just say, "I'll sign up on your list
and if you have other events, I'll help spread
the word for you."
If you can help in that way, it'd be most
appreciated, because this is what I keep getting
told by audiences that keeps me going at this:
"You have a special story.
People need to know it.
Keep telling it."
So that's why I'm here.
Well, let me take you into the story.
I'm going to start with helping you understand
the greater context of the history behind
this story.
We're going to see what you know, here.
Quiz today.
Question 1.
I said the story takes place during World
War II in Europe.
Well, when does the war in Europe start, and
then finally end?
[pause]
>>Male #1: 1939-1945.
>>Brounstein: Very good.
It started in 1939 and ends in '45.
In fact, let's even go more in depth.
When in '39 does it begin?
[pause] You don't lose any points by guessing.
Yes, go ahead.
>>Male #2: September 1st.
>>Brounstein: Very good!
September 1, 1939.
Do you know the event that triggers the start?
>>Male #3: Kristallnacht.
>>Brounstein: No, that's before the war.
That would be in November of '38.
>>Female #1: Germany invades Poland.
>>Brounstein: Very good!
Germany invades Poland.
The powers to be, Britain and France in particular,
declare war against Germany.
"Enough's enough, Adolf Hitler, and what you're
doing in Europe here.
The war will now begin."
Interestingly enough, by the way, just to
help you remember this, if you go back to
the movies, just a year past, 2010 Academy
Award winning movie, The King's Speech.
Who saw it?
Hey!
Good, they go to the movies here.
Good.
Remember the culminating scene in the movie?
King George is giving that major speech?
What's he talking about in it? [pause] You
were just worried whether he was going to
stutter or not, but what was he talking about?
[pause] The date of that speech is September
3, 1939.
That's the formal declaration by Britain.
That's what he's talking about.
"We're declaring war against Germany."
So in between the stuttering, he did pretty
good that day.
That's what's happening.
This is going to become major.
But then you said the war then ends in '45
in Europe.
By the way, when in '45?
You have 12 guesses here.
[laughter]
>>Female #2: June?
>>Brounstein: June?
Close, close.
>>Female #3: April?
>>Brounstein: Ah, between you two.
>>Female #4: May.
>>Brounstein: May, that's it!
Good, good.
What's that on that game show you can play
there.
Yes, you're very close.
Yes.
May '45, it finally ends in Europe.
August 1945, it will then end in Japan.
This war in Europe, over five and a half years,
almost six years in total.
This war, World War II, not all that long
ago when you think about it.
A lot of you certainly may have relatives
still alive who were there.
This war, when it's finally over, still true
today, is the most destructive war in humankind's
history.
Billions of dollars in property damage all
over.
55 million people will be killed in this war,
worldwide.
What we had never seen in wars prior, and
we'd seen destructive things in wars before,
more of that death will occur to civilians
than soldiers.
30 million of those will be civilians.
When you think about it, 25 million soldiers
is just humongous.
It's going to even be worse for civilians.
They're going to be caught into this war.
Nearly 2/3 of this death and destruction will
occur in Europe.
There will not be a single country in Europe,
and there's over 30 there, that will not be
impacted adversely one way or another by this
war.
If you're living in Europe during this time
period, your life will become a nightmare
after September 1, 1939.
Frans and Mien Wijnakker live in Europe.
You don't want to be there.
Now, my next question, when we look at the
greater context of this: is this also, this
story takes place during the Holocaust, capital
H. The event.
But when does the Holocaust start, and finally
end?
>>[Female #5]: 1932?
>>Brounstein: '32?
Close!
Very close.
1932 was close.
She's only one year off.
Big hint.
>>Male #4: '31!
>>Brounstein: Ah, wrong way!
>>Male #4: Wrong way.
>>Brounstein: So try again.
[laughter]
>>Male #4: '33.
>>Brounstein: 1933.
We have a winner here.
Yes, 1933 it begins.
And where?
>>Male #5: In Germany.
>>Brounstein: It begins in Germany.
And it finally ends when?
>>Male #6: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: No.
Not quite.
It still was going on after that.
1945, actually, May 1945, he was hitting it
right.
When the war finally ends, the Holocaust will
end.
These two events are separate events, but
they're going to intersect.
They'll be happening simultaneously.
12 years is the Holocaust.
Actually, it will go in phases.
When you look back over time, the first phase
just begins in Germany, and that's all before
the war.
Towards the end of the '30s, Austria, as Germany
will annex Austria.
And even towards the very end before the war,
they'll annex Czechoslovakia.
The persecution and then violence will be
happening in this first phase, especially
targeting Jews.
Then, the second phase becomes the conquering
phase.
This will start to spread throughout Europe.
The final phase--.
And that goes for a couple years.
The final phase starts late 1941, known as
the Final Solution.
That will be the mass murder phase.
For the Holocaust, this systematic, nation-sponsored,
racist effort to persecute, isolate, and mass
murder all these people on Hitler's so-called
list of Undesirables.
When it is finally over, 11 million people
will be murdered through the Holocaust.
That's more than how many live in the Bay
Area.
It's a third of the population of the whole
state of California.
[pause] Top of that list of Hitler's so-called
Undesirables?
Jews.
But they're not the only ones on the list.
But when it's finally over, for Jews, 6 million
there.
They're 6 of the 11 million.
That's nearly two out of ever three European
Jews who lived on that continent prior to
this destruction happening.
If you're part of that group of 11 million,
and you turn to any governments or country,
who's going to help you?
The answer is--
>>audience: None.
>>Brounstein: None.
At best, you might find a few individuals
who had the courage and compassion to do the
right thing, but it was not going to be the
norm.
By the way, besides Jews at the top of the
list, who was among those 5 million others?
>>Female #6: Gypsies.
>>Brounstein: Very good.
Gypsies, yes.
Who else?
>>Female #7: Communists.
>>Brounstein: Say again?
>>Brounstein: Communists, definitely.
Oh, Hitler hated them.
Yeah, they were near the top of the list.
>>Female #8: Homosexuals.
>>Brounstein: Homosexuals, yes.
>>Female #9: Handicapped.
>>Brounstein: Handicapped.
Jehovah's Witnesses.
Some Poles.
People of Slavic heritage.
The list went on.
He just got stopped before he could continue
going on.
That's the Holocaust.
If you're on that list, in most cases, people
were not prepared and didn't know what was
happening.
It was often, your life is doomed.
Not a nightmare, doomed.
Now, my last major question, when you look
at the greater context of this historical
effort.
Let's go back into the war.
What's going on in the war at the point in
time when the United States enters the war.
When does the United States get into the war,
by the way?
>>Female #10: 1941.
>>Brounstein: Just 1941.
When in '41?
>>Female #10: December 6.
>>Brounstein: Almost December 6.
>>Female #10: December 8.
>>Brounstein: Yes, December 8.
Because what happened on December 7?
>>[Female #11]: Pearl Harbor.
>>Brounstein: Pear Harbor.
Japan attacks the United States, a major Naval
base.
Next day, President Franklin Roosevelt declares
war against Japan with Congress' approval.
Well, Japan is part of the Axis powers with
Germany and Italy.
Those two countries in Europe turn around
and go, "All right, we're declaring war against
you, too, United States."
And vice versa.
The United States is finally going to get
into the war here.
Worldwide, including Europe.
We take it late 1941.
Back into Europe.
What is the situation of the war at this time?
What do you think?
What's happening?
>>Female #12: It's bad.
>>Brounstein: Well, it depends what perspective.
Explain.
>>Female #12: Well, for people in France and
the Netherlands.
>>Brounstein: Definitely.
France had already been conquered.
>>Female #12: Yeah.
Britain was barely holding on.
>>Brounstein: Very true.
What's happening in the rest of Europe?
She's on a roll here, she's getting close.
Who's winning?
>>Female #13: Germany.
>>Brounstein: Big time!
They are winning big time.
If you were betting money at this point in
time, bet on the Germans, because you'd be
winning lots of money.
Almost like winning the lottery.
In fact, how bad is it if you're not on that
side?
Well, here's what's left: at this point in
time, by the end of 1941, there were only
two countries left trying to fight against
Germany.
All the rest in Europe have either been conquered,
a few have joined as allies to Germany and
Italy, and a few were left so-called neutral.
But they're doing business actively with the
Germans, and hoping that the Germans don't
change their minds and decide to invade them.
That's the situation.
Those two who are left, you mentioned one.
Who's one of them?
>>Female #14: The United Kingdom.
>>Brounstein: Yes, the United Kingdom, or
Great Britain.
What's their status?
They've been bombed and battered, as you've
said.
They're very nervous, they've been very much
shaken.
Winston Churchill's trying to rally them around
British people.
They're wondering, "When are the Germans going
to invade with forces?"
Who's the other country left fighting?
>>Female #15: Russia.
>>Brounstein: Yeah, what we would call Russia
today.
Then, it was the bigger unit of the Soviet
Union, Russia being part of it.
What's their status at this point in time?
Well, within six months, during the last half
of 1941, German forces have overrun nearly
all the European portion of the Soviet Union.
They're within 20 miles of the capital of
Moscow.
The Soviet Union is ready to collapse.
There's life in Europe.
If you're not on the side of the Germans,
you're life is about to change, and it's going
to turn into a nightmare, including Holland,
which is where I'm going to take you.
Now, interesting enough, when the war broke
out-- We said September.
It started in September '39.
The Dutch government said, "We're going to
be neutral.
We don't want to be in this."
And during World War I 20 years earlier, they
had declared neutrality and were left alone.
Now, the Netherlands is not a big country.
Take the state of Maryland, add a little bit
more area to it.
Today, there's over 16 million people.
It's the most densely populated country in
Europe.
At that point in time, about 9 million.
Fairly densely populated then.
The little country to the south of it, Belgium,
said, "Yeah, we're going to be neutral to."
On the eastern border of those countries:
a big country called Germany.
Well, interestingly enough, after the war
broke out, nothing happened.
After a month, Poland falls.
The British and French, who said, "All right,
we're going to declare war against Germany"
watch Poland go down and go, "Oh, sorry.
Didn't help a whole lot."
Then nothing happens for about eight months.
Spring '40, the war will now pick up and go
full rage from that point on.
Sorry, Holland.
Your neutrality-- ehh!
Ptooey to that!
May 10, 1940: German forces invade the Netherlands.
The Dutch, knowing that the neutrality likely
would not be honored, were prepared.
Troops were ready.
They put up a stiff fight.
They lasted--.
Take a guess.
How long?
>>Female #16: Five days.
>>Brounstein: What's that?
I don't know.
>>Brounstein: Five days.
We have a winner.
Yes.
Exactly five days.
Wow.
Normally-- We've had some audiences-- people
who actually were small children in the Netherlands
at that time.
Just had one earlier this week.
I was at a place and she went, "Five days!"
before I even asked the question.
She was there.
She was a child of seven or eight years old.
They remember this very much.
What happened is the week is now starting
to break on.
The Dutch are actually putting up a stiff
fight.
The Germans don't like that, of course.
They turn to the government and say, "If you
keep fighting, we start bombing.
We're going to last through one of your major
cities, your commercial port Rotterdam.
So what do you want to do?"
The prime minister, in consultation with his
Cabinet and the queen there, Queen Wilhelmina,
go, "You're right.
We don't want this major destruction.
We're going to surrender.
By the way, generals, you surrendered out.
We're leaving."
They're going to be a government in exile
in London for the rest of the war.
"Good luck to you, Dutch people."
And out they go.
By the way, the Germans said, afterwards,
"Sorry.
Miscommunication."
They bombed Rotterdam anyway.
30,000 people will die in that.
And life in the Netherlands will begin to
change, because they will become an occupied
country under Nazi Germany control.
This is where Frans and Mien Wijnakker live.
Of all the different countries within Western
Europe, this country, the Netherlands, will
suffer the most for a five year period of
occupation.
Each year of this occupation, life will get
worse than the year before.
Right away, the Germans put in charge on of
their own men as a ruling governor.
Like Hitler, an Austrian Nazi, a man named
Arthur Seyss-Inquart.
He'll surround himself with his own henchmen
to run the country.
In particular, another fellow Austrian Nazi
named Hanns Rauter.
He will be the one in charge of the security
arm to keep control of the population, the
SS, as it was known as.
Brutal henchmen.
Now, life will start to change.
But not right away.
Initially, for the first few months in the
summer of 1940, it seemed quiet.
It seemed okay.
The Germans even seemed nice.
The Germans were hoping this: "They're Dutch.
You're kindred spirit to us.
You're going to be so excited we're here,
you're going to want to join the empire with
us."
Most of the Dutch said, "No thanks."
And things will start to change slowly.
But by 1941, it's going to get worse and worse
and worse.
This is what you're going to see happen: four
areas of emphasis in terms of how the Germans
ran this country, typical of many of the countries
they occupied.
1.
control the flow of information.
Well, in those days, unlike today, how did
people get their major news?
From what sources?
>>Male #7: Newspaper and radio.
>>Brounstein: Newspaper and radio.
That's it.
Two sources.
Television: we don't know what that is yet.
The internet and all its many features: who
had ever thought of that one yet?
Where's Al Gore?
It hasn't happened.
So that's not as hard to control.
Especially newspapers, because they're going
to start censoring the newspapers.
One of the early underground of resistance
efforts the Dutch do: underground newspapers,
trying to get out the real news.
The Germans want their propaganda to rule
the day.
Well, as the war goes on, the Germans don't
like that they think the Dutch are listening
to the radio, because what you start getting
on radio broadcast is broadcasts from London,
the BBC.
And even the Dutch government in exile sets
up its own radio station, Radio Orange.
The Queen starts to come on to give broadcasts
to try to rally the spirits of her Dutch people.
Well, by fall of 1943, the Germans don't like
that they think they'd already issued an edict
earlier: "Don't listen to your radio."
Try enforcing that one.
They think some of the Dutch are listening
to the radio and they're hearing these news
because the situation, the war, has started
to change.
By fall of 1943, the Germans are starting
to suffer defeats.
If you're betting money now, you're losing.
They don't want the people to know that.
Hanns Rauter, the head of the SS, September
'43, issues an edict across the country: "All
Dutch, turn in your radios."
9 million people.
Good luck trying to enforce that.
He's even conducting raids in people's homes.
"I'm going to get your radio."
Now, some Dutch, and if you know some people
from the Netherlands who fit into this category
of wry sense of humor, complied by doing this:
turning in broken down, non-functional radios.
"Here, take my radio."
Frans Wijnakker, he's going to keep his radio
hidden.
He didn't always follow the rules so well.
In addition, as they're running this country,
another area of emphasis was exploit all resources.
Well, the Netherlands is fairly well developed
economically.
There's resources to be had.
Parts, machines, raw materials.
The Germans are taking it, shipping it off
to Germany.
Take a guess: for what reason?
Why do they want that stuff?
>>Male #8: Supply the war effort.
>>Brounstein: That's right.
Supplying their war efforts.
They never had enough of their own materials
to do it, so they're taking from all the occupied
countries.
Food as well.
In addition, as they're exploiting resources,
the biggest resource to exploit: people.
During the course of the war, 350,000 people
from the Netherlands have to go work in Germany
in what was referred to as "forced labor."
That's your job.
Guess what that labor was being used for?
>>Female #17: Building the war machines.
>>Brounstein: That's right.
Building the war machines for the Germans.
Working the fields to get the food for the
war machine.
Germans never had enough of their own labor.
Their able bodied young men and women, what
are they doing?
What are they doing?
>>Male #9: In the military.
>>Brounstein: They're in the military.
Or-- By the way, there's two wars going on
that people don't often realize.
This is the Holocaust, which we now call later
on the Holocaust.
They have all this concentration camp stuff
to run.
That takes a lot of people.
Then you've got the military side of it too.
So they don't have enough people, especially
for the labor that they need, so they exploit
from other countries.
Of the 350,000 people from the Netherlands
who go into forced labor, 30,000 will not
return home alive when the war is finally
over.
That's not a job assignment you want.
Frans Wijnakker, by the way, one of his challenges:
he gets the notice that he's supposed to do
this.
If he does go, everything's going to be doomed
from what he's really trying to do.
It's going to be one of his obstacles he has
to try to overcome.
In terms of exploiting resources people, I'll
add one other example.
The last six months of the war, when the Germans
were starting to really lose, now it's starting
into 1945.
I look, maybe a few younger gentlemen in here
would fit into this category.
They wanted you.
What do they want?
What do the Germans want you for?
>>Male #10: Join the army.
>>Brounstein: That's right.
Come join our army.
By the way, it wasn't "We're recruiting."
No.
"We're drafting."
Guess who goes into hiding in large numbers
in the Netherlands in the last six months
of the war?
Young men, late teens, early 20s, mid 20s,
boom.
You'd better go and hide.
Nobody wants to serve in the German Army.
That's basically a death wish.
There's life in the Netherlands.
Not a pleasant place to be.
In addition, a third area of emphasis in running
this country: stamp out all resistance.
The Germans did not like resistance of any
form.
Like our country today, if a country came
in and conquered us tomorrow, we're not prepared
to resist anyone.
Neither were the Dutch.
Slowly, they start to do things on a small
scale.
A protest here or a strike there.
A little underground newspaper here.
It starts to pick up steam.
But the Germans react very harshly to those
things.
"You want to organize a strike, you start
doing it, we're happy to move in forces to
crush it, and arrest everybody we can.
We don't care if we get them all right, we'll
just throw them all in prison."
As it picks up and the Dutch start to do the
underground efforts of hit and run attacks,
sabotage, espionage, many are getting caught.
They try to strike some of the Dutch helpers
to the Germans.
Oh, the Germans don't like that.
Mass arrests, sometimes executions.
If you strike against one of the German authorities,
the reprisals were most brutal.
For example, February 1943, one the high ranking
Nazi officials stationed in the country was
in the Hague, the capital, was a man named
Hendrik Seyffardt.
One night, his doorbell rings.
He opens up the door.
Two Dutch resistance fighters shoot him dead.
Hanns Rauter, the head of the SS, hears about
what happened.
He rounds up 50 people and had them executed
so the public can all know it and see it.
This is the beginning of a reign of terror
that the Germans will do throughout the Netherlands
through '43, '44, and '45 until the war finally
is over.
There's life.
You want to get involved to try to help and
resist, a lot of those people were trying
to go into hiding once the Germans hear about
it.
It is not a safe place to be.
Their last major priority in running this
country was this: persecute.
Isolate.
Round 'em up from around the country and put
them into ghettos in the major city, Amsterdam.
Then deport them on the trains to the death
camps in Poland, the entire Jewish population
of the Netherlands.
Prior to the war, the Dutch Jewish population
was approximately 1 1/2% of the total.
Things started to happen, not all at once.
But before 1940, the year the initial edicts
would come out targeting Jews.
For example, here's one of the early edicts:
all Jews who work in prominent positions,
and university roles like professors, or in
government, civil service roles, you're out
of a job because you're a Jew.
Well, there weren't that many Dutch Jews in
those roles at this point in time.
But there were a few.
The most prominent was a man named Lodewijk
Visser.
His job was equivalent to what we have in
our country today, the job of John Roberts.
Civics lesson: what does John Roberts do in
the United States?
>>Male #11: He's a Supreme Court Justice.
>>Brounstein: Yes.
He's a Supreme Court Justice, in fact, yes,
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court.
That's what was basically Lodewijk Visser's
position.
He's out of a job now, before 1940 is over.
His fellow justices, in response, guess what
they said?
>>Female #18: Nothing.
>>Brounstein: Correct.
That's what they said.
Nothing.
That was the green light for the Germans to
go, "We will continue this because the Dutch
aren't going to say a whole lot or resist
a whole lot to it.
Let's go after the Jews."
It will continue throughout 1941.
The edicts just keep coming out on a monthly
if not a weekly basis that basically take
the Jewish population and isolate them from
the non Jewish population.
For employment, education, cultural and social
life, you've now been removed.
Now, when you start going out into public,
by May 1942, you have to wear this yellow
badge that identifies you as a Jew.
The public badge of humiliation.
By July 1942, the trains are now working full
blast.
The deportations are going and taking the
Jews out of the country to the death camps
in Poland.
It will continue for over a year until they
can round up all they can grab.
By the end of September 1943, they've grabbed
as many as they can.
If you're in that group, the Jews, if you
didn't figure out what's going on, you're
doomed.
If you did, you tried to go into hiding.
But will anybody help?
That, as I'm going to talk about in a moment,
it will be very challenging.
Interestingly enough, too, the Germans were
masters of propaganda.
Often, the early people they were deporting
to the concentration camps and, really, the
death camps like Auschwitz, Sobibor.
When they would arrive, they'd often have
to sign postcards, ready-made postcards.
What did the postcards say, in essence?
"Dear friends and family, life at the camp
is not so bad.
Yes, you have to work, but it's not so bad.
We look forward to seeing you soon."
So the people waiting would receive those
postcards and go, "Oh, okay."
Masters of propaganda to fool people of what
was really going to happen.
There's life in the Netherlands.
By the way, if you want to be one of those
people that says, "I don't like what's going
on" --because I'm going to talk about what
are the Dutch people doing about this-- and
you want to go help these Jewish friends or
even acquaintances, try to help them hide,
if you get caught, what happens to you?
Take a guess.
>>Male #12: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: That's right.
That's right.
Or a trip to the concentration camp, free
of charge.
You go there too.
The consequences could be the same for you.
So who wants to help the Jews?
[groans] In fact, let's talk about what's
going on with the Dutch population as they're
watching all this oppression and then persecution
to their fellow Jews.
We can put those people into four groups.
One group, I'll call them "the fearful, but
sympathetic" meaning they feel really bad
about what's going on.
They don't like it.
But they don't get involved because--
>>Male #13: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: Say again?
>>Brounstein: Well, it's not only not them,
but back to-- Pardon me?
"It's too dangerous, I'm too afraid."
That's why I said the fearful.
"Ah!
Sorry, if you ring my doorbell, I feel bad
for you, but I'm not opening my door.
I can't help."
They're mixed in with this other group that
all you can say is a larger number called
"the indifferent."
[pause] The indifferent, "I don't care.
I just want to survive this awful war and
just keep my nose down.
I don't care about what's happening to anybody.
I'm just trying to survive."
The indifferent the Germans loved, because
they're actually helping the Germans.
The Germans found many of the Dutch were very
much compliant.
For example, you work in the railroad.
You help keep the trains running.
The Germans love it, because "That's where
we get to ship out the materials we're taking
from your country, and ship out the Jews who
we're sending to the death camps.
Thanks for your help."
Just by doing their jobs.
You work for the police.
We say, "Help us, we're going to go on a raid."
Okay, you follow orders, you go help round
up people that are your own citizens.
You work for the government, oh, the Germans
are big on record keeping.
"We need to identify who the population is,
keep the records."
You're just doing your job, helping keep records,
especially who the Jews are.
"Thank you very much."
You have a lot of that going on.
The indifferent.
Put the indifferent with the fearful [pause]
and sympathetic, and you know what you have?
97% of the population, contrary to popular
myth.
There weren't a lot who were resisting this.
In fact, the last two groups, small in number,
then.
I'll put it this way: you can all see that.
One's a little bit more than the other.
This one's the resistance and its various
helpers.
Frans and Mien Wijnakker would be over here.
But they're less than this group.
This group is "the collaborators and sympathizers
with the Germans."
In fact, what people often don't realize:
Adolf Hitler had a lot of help throughout
Europe, not just in Germany.
In every country, starting in the '30s, there
was widespread fascism and Nazi-like parties
that were forming.
The Dutch had it as well.
Prior to the war, the Dutch had their own
little Nazi party called the NSB by its initials.
There were maybe about 5000 people in it.
Not a lot.
The Dutch, and much still true today, don't
like extremists on the political left or the
political right, so they've pretty much looked
at them as extremists.
"Idiots.
Ignore them."
Well, within a year of the occupation, 100,000
people have now signed up for the NSB.
Why?
Why are they joining?
What do you think?
>>Male #14] [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: Yes, they're betting on the
Germans winning.
It's not so much for safety as for-- because
they want to be on the winning side.
What do you get if you sign up and join the
winning side to help them?
Especially if there's been a Great Depression
going on as well?
>>Male #15: Jobs.
>>Brounstein: You get job opportunities.
Loot.
By the way, when they ship people out, there's
all this loot they take.
"We get the good stuff, the Germans, but NSBers,
we'll give you something for helping out."
Opportunity, perks.
In fact, in many cases, Arthur Seyss-Inquart,
running this country says, "Okay, department
head of the government.
You're not real happy with what I'm going
to do.
That's okay, you can find something else to
do.
NSBer, come in, take their job.
Are you qualified?
We don't care, you're with us.
That's what counts."
And there's other sympathizers with them who
want to cozy up to the Germans.
As an example, one of the great sympathizers
was the actual prime minister of the country
when the Dutch get conquered.
A man named Dirk Jan de Geer.
Now, he goes off in exile with the government,
into London.
But within five months, the Queen says, "Sorry,
you're out of that job.
I'm getting a new prime minister.
You go off on a diplomatic mission to Indonesia."
He doesn't do that.
Why does she remove him from the job?
Because he keeps preaching, "No, Netherlands,
don't try to cozy up with the Allied forces
like Britain and the United States.
Cozy up with the Germans.
Just cooperate with them."
So he sneaks out when he's supposed to go
to Indonesia and he goes back to the Netherlands.
The Germans gladly take him because what is
he going to do?
He publishes a pamphlet during the war.
That's what the pamphlet's saying: cooperate
with the Germans, get along.
That's what will be the best for all of us.
Wonderful sympathizer.
A man of power, here, doing this kind of thing.
There were others, obviously not in power,
who would be like, "Maybe I'm not an NSBer,
but I'm happy to help tattle."
By the way, when the authorities are trying
to find the Jews who they didn't grab the
first time who they think went into hiding,
if you helped find out that and report to
the authorities and they come and they get
the person, bonus for you.
Great way to make a little extra money.
That's life in the Netherlands.
Who's going to help?
Not a lot, because this last group, smaller
numbered, various resistance groups.
It takes time for many of them to organize.
One of the problems the Dutch had with their
resistance groups, about a half dozen eventually
get organized: they weren't united.
[claps] Good luck to you there.
You're not strong enough together, let alone
individually, to try to do much damage to
the Germans, and often, are not very effective.
Especially the hit and run, the espionage,
often, they're getting captured.
Not working really well.
Of all the resistance groups, one, over time,
becomes quite effective.
It was called the LO by its initials.
Dutch term: Landelijke Organisatie.
English translation: the National Organization
for Helping People in Hiding.
During the course of the war, by the way,
this group was led by a woman, too.
Very unusual for that time period.
By mid 1943, they've really got a national
network going and it's helping.
During the course of the war, they will help
give false identity and hide 300,000 people
from the Germans.
But by the time they get involved and do any
help, especially to the Jews who most need
it, it's too late for many.
At best, about 35,000 Jews will be able to
get into hiding.
But over a third will get caught, because
they're always on the most wanted list.
A bonus to be had if you get 'em.
That's life in the Netherlands.
Frans and Mien Wijnakker, I'll talk about
them in a moment.
They'll end up becoming helpers into this
almost by accident.
But before I talk about them, I want to tell
you about something that makes them heroic.
Then I'll be explaining why they got this
special recognition.
I want to go back to the title of this book
as I do so: Two Among the Righteous Few: A
Story of Courage in the Holocaust.
When this book was being produced last year
by my publisher Tate Publishing out of the
Oklahoma City area, the person who's job was
to design the book cover called me and said,
"I want to understand the significance of
this title, because then I can design a cover
accordingly."
I think she did a great job.
I said, "The key word in that title is the
word righteous."
It comes from a place called the Yad Vashem.
Anybody every heard of it?
Yad Vashem?
Ah, we got a few!
You know what it is?
>>Male #16: The Israeli Holocaust Museum.
>>Brounstein: Very good.
The Israeli Holocaust Museum.
Very good.
In Jerusalem, Israel.
It was started in 1953, the first of its kind.
Today, there's 100+ around the world in various
Holocaust education centers and museums.
Over the years, they've expanded.
I've been there twice myself.
It's really quite large today.
Very moving, very educational.
They get about a million visitors a year.
Well, there's a section within the museum
called the Righteous Among the Nations.
In support of that, the people who have gotten
that very special honor, they have plaques
in trees planted on the grounds all around
the museum.
That's referred to as the Avenue of the Righteous.
Well, who are these righteous?
What does this honor mean?
Those are people, non Jews, who, during the
course of the war and the Holocaust risked
their lives to help save the lives of Jews.
True heroes.
Some of them lost their life trying to help.
Among the most notable of the Righteous Among
the Nations, people are often aware of because
of the movies.
1993 Academy Award winning movie?
>>Female #19: Schindler's List.
>>Brounstein: Very good.
Schindler's List, in honor of Oskar Schindler.
He is one of the righteous, well deserved.
Frans and Mien Wijnakker are two Oskar Schindlers.
They, too, will eventually get this honor.
It usually comes years after.
For them, it came late 1983, when Yad Vashem
recognized their heroic acts.
At that point in time, Mien, the wife, had
already passed away.
She dies in 1980.
Frans is still living, so he's there to accept
this special honor.
He'll live all the way to 1994, almost the
age of 86.
Well, what did they do to earn this special
honor?
Let me focus in on that with you.
In fact, when this war breaks out, they're
just a young married couple.
Frans, at this point in time, just a little
over age 30.
Mien's a few years younger.
They live in the southeastern portion of the
Netherlands in an area of small towns and
villages, unlike the rest of the country that's
more urbanized.
They're just trying to get through the war.
What's important in their life at this point
in time is really three things.
1.
Raise a family.
By the end of 1942, they have four small children
under the age of five.
Trying to raise a family.
Anybody, any parents in the room here?
Can you imagine that?
That's hard enough in itself, and then you
got a war on top of it.
That's their life: raise the kids.
I want to be a good family, here.
They play the traditional roles which was
common in that time period.
Mien, you run the household.
Frans, you go work and support your family.
He's a semi-skilled laborer.
Works at a grain mill the town over.
Many people in that area, that's what they
were: laborers, farmers.
Not a lot of high educated people in the area
at this time period.
That's life.
Work hard, support your family.
And finally, what's important to them?
Be good Catholics.
Unlike today in Europe, and one might even
argue in the United States as well, then,
the role of the Catholic church and Protestant
faiths in other parts of the country were
very dominant in many people's lives.
Especially in their area.
In their area in particular.
Small town area.
The local parish priest was a huge authority
figure, beyond just the walls of the church.
What he said you do, you do.
What he said you don't do, you don't do.
You make sure you go to church every Sunday,
and go to confession as well.
That's their life: be good Catholics, raise
your family, work hard.
That's it.
Ordinary folk.
Well, after the war broke out, a short time
later, Frans takes a leave of absence from
his job at the mill.
He decides he can make a little bit more money
by taking Mien, and exiting, get in the countryside
here, and travel on the train to the major
cities-- two hours to Amsterdam, two hours
to the Hague-- and sell the food to people
there where food is in great need, especially
good food like that.
He starting to build up a little business.
He's a pretty good salesman.
This is going on for him.
It's not doing too badly.
Spring 1943.
He's on one of these business calls one day.
Whoops, got a question there?
>>Male #17: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: Pardon me?
>>Male #17: Basically the question was: were
the Nazis Catholics or any particular religion?
Many individuals had religion, but as a practice,
if you're part of the Nazi Party, religion
played no role in your life.
Not at all.
Let me go back to where I am in the story
here.
Frans, spring 1943.
As I said, he was on one of these business
calls.
He's in Amsterdam.
He's calling upon this doctor acquaintance
he's done business with before.
As he's doing the business there, the doctor
turns and says, "Would you be willing to help?
You see, there's this young girl we have hiding
here in the city right now.
We'd love to get her out to the countryside
where the German presence is obviously much
less.
You live somewhere in the countryside.
What's the town?"
"Dieden."
"Yeah, Dieden, okay.
Maybe you take her for three weeks.
She'll get a little fresh air, a little better
food.
Oh, by the way, she's Jewish.
Would you be willing to help?"
Frans went, "Okay!"
Not exactly knowing what he's getting into,
but he is now starting into a new venture
in his life.
Before that day is over, he meets this girl.
She's actually 14, but because of her small
stature, he thinks she's 12.
He only knows her by her false Dutch identity
name, Freetje.
By the time he gets home with Freetje on the
train, it's almost midnight.
No cell phones in that day, so he couldn't
call Mien and say, "Hey, I'm going to be late
tonight."
She's worried, but there he finally arrives.
He says, "Hey, we've got this girl.
We're going to keep her for three weeks."
Mien's reaction was, "Well, okay, let's get
her to bed."
The new business has just begun.
Now, who's Freetje?
Freetje was actually a German Jewish girl.
She and her siblings are able to get out of
Germany at the end of 1938.
Someone mentioned Kristallnacht.
Kristallnacht had happened a short time before.
The massive rampage against the Jews in Germany.
Life was taking a turn for the really worse.
Dutch were willing to take in a few thousand
what they call "unaccompanied children."
Children, not families.
They'll never see their parents again.
They'll get placed within Dutch Jewish homes
within Amsterdam.
Life, for a couple years, will go on.
She's going to learn Dutch right away, go
to school.
Life's not so bad, other than that you don't
have your parents.
But she gets to see her siblings.
She gets to meet new friends.
In fact, one of the friends that she had,
among others, that just lived down the block
from her was a girl of a similar age, who
was also German Jewish background as well.
But her whole family will get out, because
they got out in the early '30s and made life
in Amsterdam.
That family will try to stay hiding in Amsterdam,
where the German presence was the greatest.
They don't get out.
Luckily, Freetje does.
This girl, by the way, her friend I'm talking
about: a girl named Anne Frank.
Well, as you might guess, Freetje's going
to stay longer than three weeks.
In fact, within a short time after she's arrived,
Mien goes to Frans one day and says, "You
know what?
Freetje's Jewish!
Did you know that?"
"Yeah, I knew it."
"Well, she's been telling me she's got a younger
brother also in hiding in Amsterdam.
This is where he's located.
Go get him."
Zoom, on the train, brings him home.
Now there's two kids in their home.
Two Jewish children on top of their four kids.
But these two were refugees, and they're dangerous
to have.
The new business is starting to roll.
In fact, a short time later, some acquaintances
who had heard about this Frans Wijnakker,
these two older women, come on the train and
deliver to him a 17 year old girl and say,
"Hey, would you take her in?"
Frans and Mien go, "Yes, we'll take her."
Now there's three Jewish children who are
basically refugees.
The new business is starting to really pick
up.
Before long, a stranger shows up one day.
Initially, Frans is a little suspicious, because
he's asking questions.
He seems to know that he's got children in
his home.
How does he know this?
He's from the LO.
Remember that resistance organization that
helps people in hiding?
Likely, that doctor acquaintance in Amsterdam
was also part of the LO.
They started to figure out whatever people
we can help left, especially the Jews, who
most of them have been caught, who are in
the cities, if we can get them out to the
countryside, better chance to keep them hidden.
So this gentlemen, goes by a code name, starts
to explain this to Frans.
"Would you be willing to help?"
Mien comes into the conversation.
Yeah, there could be dangers in here.
"We're trying to get the remaining Jews out
first.
Would you be willing to help find places for
more in the area, take a few more in your
house, whatever you can fit?"
Frans and Mien look at each other and go,
"Okay."
Not exactly knowing what they're getting into,
but this new business now is full blast.
Now, Frans will become a broker.
As people come in and out, refugees, and he's
helping them from all ages, children to adults
to older adults.
He's going around, different acquaintances
throughout the small town area and go, "Hey!
Would you take somebody in hiding?" and often
would tell the story: "Well, the war displaced
people from their homes" or "It wasn't good,
someone got sick.
Could you take them in?"
Because in many cases, he didn't want to say,
"By the way, they're Jewish."
Because more non Jews were helping non Jews
hiding than helping Jews.
Everyone he's helping were Jews.
Total strangers to him.
That's what he would be doing.
Seeing if he could get people-- "And by the
way, we could pay you a little money for it,
too."
So he's getting people to help out, one by
one.
The challenges now start to pick up in this.
They certainly learned.
Shortly after both Frans and Mien go, "Uh-oh.
This is dangerous and there are numerous challenges."
For example, one of the most common ones you'd
hear, the term would be "betrayed", meaning
the person we have in our home.
"They've been exposed.
We think people know about it.
The authorities come to get them, of course,
Frans, they're going to come to get us.
We're going to be doomed.
We've been betrayed.
Get them out of here!"
Then there'd be the mad scramble to find another
place.
Take them into another house temporarily.
He's dealing with this a lot.
There are numerous other challenges.
When I reflect back on the challenges and
dangers that they ended up having to deal
with and face, I am stunned that they persisted.
Because most people, like us, we would have
quit and ran fast.
But they had the courage and compassion to
continue.
Let me tell you just one other challenge among
many.
It deals with the first adults they take into
hiding in their own home.
First adult they took in, was around the fall
of 1943, was a gentleman named Lou.
He's a architect by trade.
He was already in hiding in Amsterdam, was
able to sneak out and come into the home of
Frans and Mien.
Luckily, his trade was very helpful, because
he will help design and build within the Wijnakker
home a hiding room.
By 1944, when the German presence starts to
increase in their area, that's going to be
very valuable to have.
But Lou, similar in age to Frans, is not with
his wife.
She got out from Amsterdam a little bit later,
a short time afterwards.
Unbeknownst to Frans-- I mean, excuse me,
unbeknownst to Lou, Frans actually placed
her nearby.
They often didn't want young married couples
together.
His wife, Angelien, is at a place for about
a month.
Then she gets betrayed, gets sent out in the
middle of the night and say, "Go find the
house of Frans and Mien Wijnakker.
I think it's over here."
Luckily, she's able to find it without getting
caught.
Then has an emotional reunion with her husband
Lou.
Great.
Frans and Mien say, "Welcome.
We can keep you here."
But a short time after arriving, Angelien
says, "I have a secret I can't keep secret
any longer.
I'm pregnant."
How are you going to have a baby under these
conditions?
These are not normal conditions.
What are you going to do about that?
In fact, one of the choices: send her away.
This is just among many of the challenges.
You can see where they get this award, righteous
among the nations, in years later.
Because, when this is finally over, and all
these dangers all around them, when the liberation,
almost after their nearly two year effort,
they will save the lives of at least two dozen
Jews from certain death.
And nobody will get caught.
You can see why they're true heroes.
The last piece, before I open up to more questions,
is I mentioned at the beginning I also have
a very personal connection to this story.
I'm going to read you a little excerpt from
the book to give you some insight into that.
Let me set up the piece I'm about to read
by first introducing my number 1 supporter
in this special journey I've been going on.
It happens to be with me today.
It happens to be my wife, Leah Baars.
Here she is.
[applause]
>>Brounstein: Yes, please.
[applause continues, then ends] Well, my wife
Leah, and her family, are actually immigrants
from the Netherlands themselves.
They moved to the United States when she was
just shy of 14.
They moved to LA.
She takes to American television right away.
Her mother will worry what's going to happen
with her.
But actually, surprising her mother, she goes
on to UCLA and graduates from there, then
moves up here to the Bay Area, ends up having
a wonderful career as a school psychologist,
raises two young adult daughters today.
A little bit later in life, picks me up.
We've been married a little over five years
now.
Well, it's spring 2009.
She has not been back to her original homeland
now for 25 years, because life got in the
way.
If you've ever lived somewhere else, you have
those roots.
That often has a very emotional pull.
She'd been talking with me for a while, and
I've never been.
"We need to do a special trip and go and spend
some time there."
Spring 2009, we go for a six week trip traveling
throughout the Netherlands.
Along the way, we stumbled into something
by accident that I thought was so significant
that I end up writing a letter to her two
daughters, because I thought it would be important
to know.
That's the piece I'm going to read you about
here.
One last thing before I do that.
If you knew my wife Leah as a child in the
Netherlands, you didn't know her by the name
Leah so much.
You knew her more by her Dutch nickname Ineke.
Please keep that in mind as I read this piece.
"Chapter 1: Historic Moment.
Dear Shoshana and Alana" -- that's her two
daughters-- "Today is Tuesday, May 26, 2009.
I'm writing to share more than just travel
stories from the wonderful journey your mom
and I are having.
I want to document something to you that I
hope you will find of much value for your
own family history.
While I know some of the history, and you
probably do too, coming in contact with the
reality of it merges mind and heart into something
of great significance.
I will explain shortly.
Being in the Netherlands, much more than in
the United States, one is reminded of World
War II and the Holocaust as well.
When we started our trip in Amsterdam, we
visited the Anne Frank house.
It is a wonderful educational museum.
Last Friday, we visited the museum in sight
of Camp Westerbork.
Before World War II, there were 140,000 Jews
who lived in the Netherlands.
107,000 perished during the Holocaust.
Westerbork was the deportation center the
Nazis used to ship the Dutch Jews off to the
death camps in Poland.
We arrived last evening in the city of Eindhoven
in the south of the country.
Of the places your mom's family lived prior
to immigrating to the US, Eindhoven was where
they were the longest.
Before arriving there yesterday, we stopped
in an old town named Ravenstein.
It is the big small town in an area of villages
in the southern section of the country.
It is also near where your grandparents, Opa
and Oma, were hidden during the war.
As we stop and walk around the charming 1600s
historic downtown of Ravenstein, all two blocks
of it, we spot a tourist information office.
We go in, and your mom asked the staff members
about the location of an old church in the
nearby small town of Dieden, and if the home
that once belonged to Frans Wijnakker is still
next to it.
For the older folks in this area, which the
three office people on hand were, the name
of Frans Wijnakker is a notable one.
They tell your mom not only how to get to
this church, but also that one of the Wijnakker's
sons still lives in this particular house.
So off we go, down the road, to Dieden.
About ten minutes later, we find the church
in question.
We park our car at the old church and walk
over to the house next door to it.
The house has a long driveway.
As we walk up the driveway, we see a few people
sitting at a table in the front yard on this
warm day.
We see the world "Shalom" written on the front
side of the house, probably a foot in side.
Your mom boldly walks up to the gentleman
sitting there and says in Dutch, "Hello, I'm
Ineke Baars."
A roar goes up along with a warm handshake.
This man, and his wife sitting with him, know
who Ineke Baars is, and much more, the significance
related to her.
In the next few minutes, the Dutch starts
flying and phone calls start happening.
Within ten minutes, his youngest sibling,
Irene drives over and joins in this lively
discussion.
The man who has greeted us is Frans Wijnakker,
Junior.
He's the youngest son of the aforementioned
Frans Wijnakker.
His father Frans, with the support of his
mother Mien, saved your grandparents and your
mom, baby Ineke, during World War II.
They all survived the Holocaust because this
Catholic man and his wife hid them and other
Jews, and helped even more hiding from the
Nazis.
Do you recognize the significance of this
moment?
Frans' son and his wife, also named Irene,
visited Israel themselves last year.
They showed us a blown up picture of the memorial
plaque and tree planted in Yad Vashem's Avenue
of the Righteous section in honor of their
parents, which is when the historic significance
of what I was witnessing really hit me.
After visiting for over an hour, they've invited
us to come back Wednesday evening.
They have three other siblings who are all
alive and live in the local area.
Your mom will likely meet more of the Wijnakker
who she has not seen in 25 years."
[pause]
I'll open up the floor to your questions,
comments.
>>Male #18: I just have a question, in your
story- telling, it seems like a quite easy
decision for those couples to help those Jewish
people.
But I guess in such a situation, it's quite
dangerous.
It's actually a huge decision to make to help
them.
What do you think is the force or the motivation
to make the decision to help so many Jewish
people?
>>Brounstein: Yes, great question here.
As you can hear as I told it, and you would
get the same thing if you read this more in
depth, is they stumbled into this by accident.
But there was things thinking that Frans had
and Mien definitely along with him that said,
"People are asking for help.
That's a Dutch thing to do.
You help."
That wasn't a Dutch thing to do, as we find
out.
But there was just that thing of "People are
asking for help."
We even heard, years later, as we now know
the family, the siblings, that he always wanted
to make a difference in his life in some way.
So it was like this.
But it's almost like they stumbled into it.
And they don't realize it at first.
Along the way, they get scared, even, and
almost back away, but then they don't.
They'll continue.
But they definitely get challenged.
But there's a moral fiber and character that
you can see come out that you don't always
know the why, you have to draw your own conclusions,
but at least it came through.
Thank God it did.
Great question, thank you.
What is your name?
>>Female #20: Rachel.
>>Brounstein: Rachel.
>>Female #20: What happened when you came
back from that visit with the family that
Wednesday?
>>Brounstein: Ah, great question, Rachel.
>>Female #20: Thank you.
>>Brounstein: Thank you very much.
Great question.
As you finish reading here, it's a Monday.
We stumbled into this area by accident.
The Wijnakker family know who Ineke Baars
is.
This is Ineke Baars right here, folks.
They started juts talking to their other siblings
and who can come.
You can imagine that.
Somebody who you have not seen in 25 years
shows up.
You get a call from maybe a sister or brother
that says, "Hey, can you come over tomorrow
night?"
Most of us would say, "Oh, I'm busy, I've
got this going on.
I'm sorry.
Give my regards."
Because they heard Ineke Baars was in town,
all five siblings come, bringing their spouses
with them.
They're excited to see her.
The last time she had been there, I said it'd
been 25 years.
It was the summer of 1984.
She traveled from San Francisco, with then
her oldest daughter who was five, to go visit
Frans Wijnakker, who was still alive, because
the local area had heard about this special
honor he gets from Yad Vashem, Righteous Among
the Nations.
So they throw a parade for him, to say, "Here's
really a local hero."
Now they recognize that.
Who's in the parade?
Ineke Baars.
But then, as the years go by, life got in
the way.
This has been a happy reunion.
We are still in touch with the family today,
which has been a nice part of the journey.
So thank you for your question.
>>Male #19: How do we take the lessons we
learned from the dark period and apply it
to the world today?
>>Brounstein: Good question, good question.
Let me throw it back to all of you.
What lessons can you take?
How can you apply it to your life today?
From this story.
It's a great question.
Let me hear a few of your thoughts, and I
can offer a thought as well.
>>Male #20: I think all state [indistinct]
like the government and other entities should
take minority oppression very seriously.
Whenever any country moves towards minorities'
oppression or at least has tendencies towards
that, I think countries react very forcefully
to arrest that trend.
I think that's the lesson, because that can
actually get bigger and much worse if you
leave it.
>>Brounstein: Yeah, that's a very good point.
In essence, too, and I've often had people,
to your great question here, speak up, going,
"Do I have that courage to speak out when
I see something going wrong?"
Discrimination, oppression.
Because those things are happening.
Sometimes we don't notice them.
It's easier to get caught up in our good life
and not see it.
That's one of the lessons people will often
comment as, "Can I speak out, whether our
government will do anything or not?
Can at least I speak out and say something
and try to help?"
Definitely is a great lesson you can take
away from this story.
Others?
Other thoughts on that?
[pause] Let me throw one to you, and I want
you to comment.
One of the things, and this has been the neat
part of, I've talked about this in a variety
of venues as I've shared this story.
But in workplaces in particular, what I'm
being asked often to emphasize: this story
is a story of ethics.
How's this a story of ethics?
What are ethics?
What do you think?
>>Male #21: It's the sense of doing the right
thing.
>>Brounstein: Uhuh.
I think you can take down your life every
day.
How do you treat people?
You get sometimes challenges in life.
You could get away with doing it dis--.
Is that the right thing?
I think most people, in my experience, they
know deep down what's right and what's not.
These people not only were able to do that,
they did it with their life at risk.
How many of us are willing to do that?
We don't usually have that pressure, thank
goodness.
But can we know right from wrong?
For those of you who are parents in the room,
are you teaching that to your children?
Those are definitely stories.
I think that one of the neat things is we've
got reacquainted and me, acquainted, with
the Wijnakker family.
You can see with all five of the siblings
there is a moral character.
You know their parents passed it on to them.
They think it's important to care about other
people.
One of the messages from the story: can you
care about people beyond yourself?
Just in doing your job.
Team members you work with.
If you can, you can be a valuable team member.
Let alone a parent, person in the community.
There's all those opportunities.
Great question.
Thank you for that.
Let me take a couple more here before we'll
wrap up.
Got one?
Please.
>>Male #18: Can I ask one more?
I remember you mentioned three things about
the couple.
One is they are just ordinary southern couples,
and they have four children.
You also emphasized that they are Catholic.
Do you think this is very important, Catholic
or Christian, like their religion really helped
them to make such a decision to really help
the people?
>>Brounstein: Ah.
Good question.
All right.
It's one of those things I'd say, "Read more
about it and I'll let you draw your own conclusions."
I'll answer briefly.
I'd say my answer is yes and no.
Their religion was important to them, and
it may have played a role in what they did,
but in the reality of living their lives,
if they'd been following the religious leadership
they had, they would not have been involved.
The religious leadership, the clergy, weren't
always setting the examples.
One could argue that's maybe still the case
today sometimes.
It various, of course.
One of the biggest thorns for Frans in this
secret work that he's doing, trying to help
save the lives of people, was his local parish
priest.
It was different throughout the country.
Some were helpful, some weren't.
Some could care less, you don't bother, and
others would say, "I'll get involved."
In the Netherlands, they'll lose over 90 Protestant
and Catholic clergy who will get executed
or die in the concentration camps because
they do speak out.
Many won't.
He had the thorn in this case.
So it's a mixed bag, who's going to help,
who's not.
Is their religion driving them?
I think if you look more just as you draw
conclusions, there was a moral character.
Whether it came from their Catholicism or
not, it was there.
If the Catholicism was not supporting it,
they would have the moral character to go,
"We're going to still do the right thing."
The ethics comes through.
Great question.
Let's make sure we get another question answered.
Right, yeah, we always want to make sure of
this one here.
Nadine, can you come on up here for a moment?
We always want to make sure people get this
one.
[pause]
>>Nadine: [laughs] Whatever happened with
that baby?
>>Brounstein: Ah!
Good question, good question.
Remember that challenge I mentioned, the baby?
The woman is pregnant there?
Uhuh.
Anyone want to answer that?
What happens?
[pause]
>>Male #22: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: Say that again.
Say that again.
>>Male #22: [inaudible]
>>Brounstein: No, no, no, it was real.
It was real.
[laughs] She was about five months along.
You can't hide that anymore.
It wasn't just a pillow in there.
I think you were starting to figure it out.
>>Male #22: Are we with the baby today?
>>Brounstein: We are with the baby today.
[Leah Baars sings a note]
>>Male #22: It looks just the same.
>>Brounstein: Yes, yes.
>>Baars: Oh, how do you know that?
>>Brounstein: Have you seen the pictures?
You've seen the pictures.
>>Baars: Oh, you've seen the pictures.
>>Brounstein: Yeah, yes.
I said I have a meaningful, personal connection
to the story.
I brought her with me.
[applause] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Your applause.
[laughs] One of the things here, and I only
knew about this in terms of I knew her origins.
I didn't know the specifics behind it.
She's learned a lot in terms of all that went
going on there, not just for herself.
Well, Chapter 9 is the short answer to the
question.
But this is one of their biggest dilemmas.
Because if you think about it, how are you
going to have a baby under these circumstances?
You can't go to the hospital.
Good luck trying to find a doctor, because
most doctors are going to run from this.
They don't want the authorities to know what
they're doing.
It's too dangerous to touch a Jewish mother.
So Frans and Mien have to deal with this.
I'll just give you a little insight, because
they will decide that they will try to help.
They have that-- Remember that first couple
they take into hiding, Lou and Angelien?
Well, that's her parents.
They agree with them, this is the strategy:
however we get this pregnancy done, get the
birth done, because we don't know how yet,
we're going to register her as our own child
with the authorities.
We can keep her with our children.
In the event that danger comes, authorities
show up: "It's just one of our children.
We can keep her outside."
That's pretty courageous.
They will perform a miracle.
And I get to enjoy the miracle every day.
I say, "Thank God for the courage and compassion
of Frans and Mien Wijnakker."
Thank you all.
Great audience.
Thank you so much.
[applause]